la suya ha sido una vida de promesas y
duelos nació el 20 de noviembre de 1942
en scranton pensilvania en una familia
de origen irlandés de niño enfrentó su
primer gran reto el tartamudeo tardó
años en superarlo pero en el proceso
creó su propia fórmula del éxito
perseverar y aprender a levantarse se
graduó como jurista en 1969 y cuatro
años después fue elegido como uno de los
senadores más jóvenes del país pero el
que en ese momento parecía sus sueños
dorados se había empañado por la primera
de varias penas en 1972 se juramentó
como legislador pero lo hizo desde el
hospital en el que sus hijos
hunter y vogue luchaban por sobrevivir
luego de que un accidente
automovilístico acabara con la vida de
naomi su hija menor y de neila su esposa
las leyes y las sonrisas de boy hunter
le dieron la energía para seguir y con
el paso del tiempo formó una nueva
familia junto a su todavía esposa jill
con quien tuvo a su hija ashley se abrió
paso hasta la presidencia del comité
judicial
del senado fue coautor en 1994 de una
ley contra el crimen que aún le genera
críticas por haber disparado los
encarcelamientos de delincuentes no
violentos posteriormente lideró el
comité de relaciones exteriores de la
cámara alta hasta que obama lo eligió
como su fórmula
fue hace más de 10 años pero lo recuerdo
como si fuera ayer estaban al borde del
abismo pero barack y yo apostamos por
ustedes tuvo una sola condición ser el
último hombre en el despacho con el
presidente antes de la toma de una
decisión importante su experiencia y su
rol de negociador fueron cruciales para
que la ley de salud asequible el
obamacare se convirtiera en realidad
pero en 2015 la tragedia tocó de nuevo a
su puerta cuando su hijo bobo murió de
cáncer cerebral
[Música]
brevemente dejo de lado la política pero
asegura que fue la marcha de neonazis
que se registró en charlotteville en
2017 la que lo impulsó a lanzarse en una
batalla por el alma de la nación
[Música]
cierre los ojos y recuerde lo que vio
neonazis supremacistas blancos saliendo
de los campos con antorchas encendidas
guayre con las venas hinchadas cantando
ella misma dice se presenta arrojada por
europa en los años 30 inductores en el
pasado quedaron sus frustradas
aspiraciones presidenciales con las que
luchó por llegar a la casa blanca en
1988 y 2008 ahora apuesta nuevamente por
la oficina oval en medio de
señalamientos por un presunto conflicto
de intereses mientras fue vicepresidente
en el caso que implica a su hijo hunter
cuando fue directivo de la empresa
ucraniana de gas budismo
creo que necesitamos el liderazgo de un
eeuu que busque reducir las tensiones
abrir las líneas de comunicación unirnos
de nuevo para sanar y tener esperanza
curtido por tantas experiencias y tras
47 años en la arena política promete
unir al país y afrontar con mesura y sin
populismos el impacto de la mayor crisis
sanitaria de la historia reciente